David, do you think Joe Biden has
any shot at passing that tax plan?
So we talked about this a little bit last week
with Nick Majilis from Ritholtz Wealth Management.
I think that there's two scenarios. Without
the Senate, it's just a hard no. I don't see
how on earth Joe Biden gets a tax reform done if
he doesn't have the Senate. Now with the Senate,
you've got a debate. And what's really
important for many of you to understand
is that Joe Biden, although he may be to
your right, has put out a tax plan that
is well to the left of many Senate Democrats
who Joe Biden would need to pass tax reform.
There are many on the left who are upset that
Joe Biden has no wealth tax in his tax plan.
A wealth tax is not popular among Senate Democrats
if and until the Senate becomes far more left than
it is right now. A wealth tax has no chance
of passing whatsoever. So you are going to
see if Joe Biden gets the Senate. You'll see some
provisions that are likely to pass, for example,
a return of the top marginal tax rate
to thirty nine point six percent. It was
dropped to 36 percent or maybe thirty seven.
Thirty six. Thirty seven under Donald Trump.
That would almost certainly go back to thirty nine
point six percent. It is seen by the Democratic
establishment and to be frank, by some in the
Republican establishment as something that on
paper looks nice, were raising the top tax rate
for the richest people. Many people who are in
that top tax rate are not earning money through
wages anyway, so they are not subject to that.
You will almost certainly see that uncapping
Social Security at four hundred thousand dollars.
I think there's no way in hell that that
passes, not because of Joe Biden, but because of
Senate Democrats, as you may know right now, you
pay Social Security tax or you and your employer
pay Social Security tax on the first 130000 or
so dollars in earnings. And then Social Security
tax goes to zero. Once you get past that one
hundred and thirty thousand, whether you make
two hundred thousand a year, a million, 10 million
a year, you pay zero. Once you get past that cap,
Joe Biden's proposal is at 400000 plus the tax
kicks back in and it goes uncapped. I think there
is no way in hell that Senate Democrats passed
that Senate Democrats are just too conservative to
see that happen, the increase in the capital gains
tax rate. I think that that is a 50/50, but that
there are ways it gets done with some negotiation.
And then I think that the stepped up basis
provision that Joe Biden wants to eliminate is
probably a long shot. I won't explain it all now
because I've explained it in a number of previous
videos. Will there be a new higher tax bracket?
So even if you raise the top tax bracket from
thirty seven to thirty nine point six percent,
as Joe Biden wants to do, many progressive
economists and lawmakers say, well, we need
we need a higher tax bracket. Fine. You get into
the highest tax bracket at five hundred thousand a
year in income, but when you get to two
million a year in income, then it should
go to 43 percent. And when you get to five million
a year in income, it should go to 48 percent and
so on. You could have that configured a number of
different ways. I would be shocked if we saw that
again, because the Democratic Party in
the Senate right now is well to the right
of where Joe Biden has run. And that's my thought
on the major provisions of Joe Biden's tax plan.
If Democrats take the Senate, I just don't see any
path forward. If Democrats don't take the Senate.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I want to hear from you. We've got a
great bonus show for you today.
Remember, the number one way
to access the bonus show is to grab a membership
at Join Pakman Dotcom. Do it. I'll see you then.